you know what aren't usually rectangular
watches sure the Apple watch is the most
stylish fully feature not to mention
best-selling SmartWatch to date but it
is now round 2 for the competition
literally this week Motorola and Samsung
announced the round screen smartwatches
but what's different about them besides
their curves I'm going to find out
my first stop Samsung Samsung has had
quite a number of smartwatches over the
past few years but the gear s2 feels
like the first one that's actually worth
paying attention to and that's because
it's got this rotatable ring around the
screen that helps with navigating the
watch has a one point two inch diameter
touch screen but rather than just poke
it with your finger you can use the
unfortunately named rotary UX to move
between screens or select apps it's
similar to Apple's digital crown but
it's way more natural and fun to use
this is so much more fun than my old
swatches interestingly the interface is
not powered by Google's Android wear but
Samsung's own home-brewed Tizen software
the interface seems smartly designed
although I'm not sure what they were
thinking with this keyboard the gear s2
looks a little bit more sporty but the
gear s2 classic is smaller and has
leather bands both will be available
with NFC to work with Samsung pay and a
version will have built-in 3G but with
the Samsung hasn't specs the new moto
360 makes up for in style the new
version just like the Apple watch is
really customizable plus it comes in two
sizes which is great news for those of
us with small wrists other than this new
moto body app the new Android wear
powered moto 360 doesn't really do
anything different than the old one but
there are way more design options and
now it comes in two sizes I thought the
rose gold 42 millimeter version looked
pretty darn good on me probably because
it was designed for women that said it
does still look pretty chunky on my
small wrist though not as chunky as the
Samsung the Moto 360 will ship the end
of September and we'll start at $300
Samsung's gear will be coming out this
fall but no pricing has been announced
after seeing both of these devices my
first impression is that both
Samsung and Motorola are making serious
headway on SmartWatch hardware design
from especially into that moto 360 but
the big question comes with software
stay tuned for full reviews of these to
see if they really run circles around
Apple's watch ok I really out of puns
now that's all folks